[Music]
Jennifer Lawrence proves Comfort is key
rocking flip-flops at the Cannes Film
Festival it's just not a drill on Sunday
Jayla stunned on the red carpet in the
south of France sporting this Christian
Dior Couture cherry red gown with a
diamond necklace but when the Oscar
winner lifted her gown to walk down the
steps fans caught a glimpse of her
unexpectedly casual Footwear black thong
sandals it was a very easy easy decision
this is why we love jaylop she keeps it
real I mean who wants to cram their feet
into five inch heels and walk down a
flight of stairs right that's scary yeah
Jen's probably trying to avoid another
carpet conundrum courtesy of her fashion
oh no the actress tripped as she made
her way to the stage to collect the SAG
award for outstanding female actor in a
leading role in 2013 teen for her role
in Silver Linings Playbook are you gonna
walk me home
your poor social skills you have a
problem I have a problem you say more
inappropriate things and appropriate
things you scare people I tell the truth
you're mean well I'm not telling the
truth and shortly after that she did it
again stumbling on the stairs to collect
her Oscar for the same role what went
through my mind fell down uh
a bad word that I can't say
that starts with f with that little
stomach
stump State Hugh Jackman jumped up to
give you I just heard about that because
I didn't know because I was so in my
like cloud of like I want to die I had
no idea that actually fixes the whole
moment but it's a memorable moment no
one will ever forget it for many reasons
including that and over the years I can
change it gradually to he pushed me down
one year later she did it again getting
out of her car at the 2014 Oscars now I
understand is it true that you actually
tripped on the red carpets and I there
was a cone outside my car and I ran over
the cone I the cone hit me I went fully
down I don't know how there's no dirt on
my dress I do have a goose egg on my
shin now I think it's a good omen that
you actually fell tonight really yeah
because last year you uh did a little
tripping and you won the Oscar yeah I
think I just kind of trip all the time
so I'm not I'm not gonna get my hopes up
on that fast forward about a decade and
a handful of memorable movies later and
Jen's now Mary she and her hubby cook
Moroni welcomed their first kiddo
together a son named Psy back in 2022.
what are you looking forward to most
about motherhood God I don't know I'm
just gonna have to find out that you're
gonna be brilliant thank you and after
size birth Jen took some time out of the
spotlight something she opened up to ET
about in 2021. it's been a minute since
we've seen you out here on these carpets
I feel yeah been a minute since we've
seen anybody it's been a couple years we
have spoken out about being a little
anxious maybe nervous about getting out
to the carpets again and so is
everything feeling okay I mean I know
we're your first interview yeah you you
really are welcome no it's okay I mean
it's great I'm excited to be here like
with the whole cast and I'm so excited
about this movie yeah and for people to
see it well we gotta say Jen we're glad
you're back we sure missed shoe
[Music]